one of the great philosophers on whom I
do a good bit of scholarship and also
have taught a number of times is Thomas
Hobbes one of the I considered him
fathers of early modern philosophy a lot
of people would say that Descartes is
the father of modern philosophy but i
would say that Hobbes certainly deserves
to be called the second father of a new
way of doing things and although I am a
hob scholar in that I've you know
published quite a few pieces on Hobbs
over the years I'm not a Hobbesian that
is I'm not somebody who puts him fourth
as you know the way in which we ought to
view things as a matter of fact I'm
attracted to Hobbes in part and I'll
tell you more about this a bit later
precisely because I think that he shows
us how things could go drastically wrong
not only in his own times but in the
21st century and also as they did in the
20th century so I'm not a Hobbesian but
I am you could say in some respects of
Hobbes admirer but also somebody who
whose admiration is mixed with with fear
and you can tell just how much i read
and re-read Hobbes because this is my
every man's version of Leviathan I'm not
sure where the back bit went off to I
mean all the words are still in there
and admittedly I don't really read much
in part 3 and 4 and the Leviathan but
parts one and two you see they've gotten
quite a bit of use out of them there's a
ton of underlining and read underlining
in many different colors in here as well
I first started reading Hobbs you know I
think if I if I'm recalling this right
back as an undergraduate at Lakeland
College in a Lakeland University which
side note no longer has a philosophy
program there
lot of us in philosophy at the time but
I had to read him free a modern
philosophy class and I don't remember
being particularly impressed by most of
what I was reading it was in that thanh
anthology so it wasn't the totality of
Leviathan I did enjoy you know reading
his depiction of the state of nature i
found you know his diction a bit
difficult myself to to read but that was
just because i hadn't gotten used to his
own way of talking you know a lot of
times when we have ancient and early
modern authors in translation because
the translators will make them as
up-to-date as possible those
translations are sometimes a bit more
readable than you know 16th 17th 18th
century literature and so Hobbs suffered
a bit from that for for me at least as I
started you know thinking more and more
in terms of political philosophy and
reading the Leviathan as a systematic
document which is what Hobbes intended
for it not just looking at this chapter
or this chapter by itself but looking at
the totality of what he was putting
together I found myself becoming more
and more impressed by by Hobbes thought
he was somebody who was a staple I
taught him many times early on as a
matter of fact I think the very first
time that I got to teach him I was still
a graduate student I was teaching a
class on philosophy politics and justice
or perhaps the flaw maybe was philosophy
of politics law and justice or something
like that but Leviathan was something I
had my students read and then i would i
would actually use it in quite a few
ethics classes as well as you know
classes on 19th century philosophy or
intro classes where i wanted to get the
students to you know grapple with some
classic political philosophy and you
know i found myself you know struck by
by the scope of his thought and by its
implications particularly for conflict
in the
present so you know over the course of
time I ended up doing quite a bit of
presenting and and some of those
presentations get turned into articles
one of the ones that I had early on was
in this journal octa philosophic ah and
that's the laws of nature as moral norms
in Hobbes Leviathan that ended up being
turned into a forum because some of the
people who were involved with octa
philosophical thought that my reading of
Hobbes was a little bit too radical and
and they they disagreed with it so we
had a scholarly debate about that also
in octave philosophical i'll put links
to those that the article and then the
forum discussion about it here and then
i published another one in philosophy
and social criticism this one was called
reason is danger and remedy for the
modern subject in Hobbes Leviathan and
in it I was arguing that Hobbes is you
know particularly important to read
because he articulates this this
situation that were caught in and one of
the one of the ways in which people will
often view you know matters and then
sort of he provides a solution which is
a solution that many people have taken
and it's a solution ultimately of
totalitarianism Hobbes was was struck in
part by you know the need for social
order in watching an English Civil War
unfold and that English Civil War ended
up producing what's arguably one of the
first early totalitarian societies you
know thankfully a fairly short one you
know and Hobbes is is writing you know
in response that you can take out a lot
of his sort of you know references to
you know early modern politics and the
ins and outs of the English scene and
apply it in a much larger so
and you can get this this sort of look
it's either Anarchy or it's a poorly
functioning society in which there
really isn't any justice and it's just
force and you know things are going to
fall apart sooner or later or they're
just going to keep on going through and
new elites are going to replace old
elites engaging an ideological conflict
with each other or you can have this
well ordered society of the sort that
I'm setting out which by the way is
going to have to be enforced by
authority which will extend not only to
you know what you do but what you think
or what you teach Hobbes thinks that all
of this can be set out and this is
something that's very revolutionary
about Hobbes he thinks all of this can
be set out in a form of a new social or
political science what he would call
moral science right and this has been an
attractive prospect for many people I
would you know a lot of people want to
say you know that Nietzsche should be
the person that we look to about how
things could go wrong and all that I
actually think that Hobbes is in a
certain respect more apropos more
influential even in indirect ways than
the Nietzsche is he shows us how these
dilemmas can work out so one of the
other things that I wrote which never
ended up getting published was for a
volume that a colleague was working on
and it had to do with contemporary
African politics and how to avoid
falling into Hobbesian dilemmas because
when there is not a strong civil society
and there is a history of you know
revolts and power struggles and not only
you know in terms of like the political
system but you might call it the
cultural or ideological system also gets
involved so there's no way to take a
objective although everybody saying
their objective there's no way to take a
purely objective stance it's it's easy
to see why things that look similar to
Hobbs's Commonwealth would be where
things would go and I think
that that usually can't be realized
totalitarian societies are in many
respects even worse than the the
anarchic breaking down unfair unjust
societies that they they are used to
replace but you can see why that sort of
thing would be would be attractive so I
think that and I still think this today
I just haven't had the time to much
follow-up scholarship on hubs I think
that Hobbes is actually outlining a
fundamental human problematic one that
becomes particularly acute in in
modernity and continues through so I
brank him actually up you know in in the
thinkers of the first rate and I look at
this book Leviathan as one of the great
works of Western philosophy that that
everybody should read I do have a few
other things I've published here and
there on Hobbs 11 paper that I I don't
know if I'll ever get it reworked and
sent out for publication and hobbes and
there was a discussion about could he
actually be a virtue at the system I
said well he does talk about virtue but
it if he is a virtue ethicist it's in a
very different way than then other
virtue ethicists would would you know
understand that to be but maybe i don't
all see if i'll send out sometime right
now I consider it to be an orphaned
paper but I did publish another piece
about the five states of nature in
Hobbes Leviathan I think that there's
there's a number of different ways that
he construes the the famous state of
nature and I provide an exegetical
argument for that so i'll put a link to
that as well you might find that
interesting i gave that to a new online
journal that was looking for for papers
so in any case that that's a little bit
about why i think people should study
thomas hobbes well I think his ideas are
worth examining and thinking through
again I don't I'm not endorsing him
I don't I don't agree with him as a
matter of fact he kind of makes me
worried as I read through the stuff but
but I have a kind of fascination with
this mindset that he articulates and how
well he's able to address a lot of
issues that that come up and so I see
him as somebody whose whose ideas
whether you know coming directly from
Hobbs or formulated in other ways
because other people can arrive at
similar ideas will be attractive to many
people in situations of intractable
social and political conflict in
ideological conflict and so I think it's
very important to to look at at him and
to think about how we would move past
this where the weak points in his
arguments are but you know all that said
I really enjoy working at him I really
enjoy teaching him and I probably will
continue to do both of those over the
course of my career